a year ago after a brutal accident I
lost my life and I chose to become
Bionic I had to rethink my world my my
identity my purpose my physicality all
the pieces of my past endeavors they all
came together I had learned the barriers
are entirely in your mind and you can
choose to either accept those barriers
or you can have the guts to to dance the
tango with the unknown to take that
first step and then see what unfolds I
think that's what being an explorer is
all about I truly believe that romantic
notion of finding tunes and going beyond
the barriers and and venturing into the
unknown all those things are just a
choice
[Music]